what's going on guys this is rob and as
you guys know when it comes to the
marvel cinematic universe leaks and
rumors and things like that come out
seemingly all the time and so while
these leaks are not necessarily brand
new in fact they've kind of been around
since october of last year what is
coming out is a lot of information from
the back which is really just kind of
confirming these leaks as seemingly
being accurate now if you guys don't
know what these are they've kind of been
the talk of the town for the last couple
days or so not necessarily overshadowing
batman but they have been a big talk
among the marvel cinematic universe
community so let's talk about the first
one now here's what the first leak says
the mid-credits scene is doctor strange
sleeping after the events of the
multiverse of madness and he has a
nightmare where he sees himself training
an apprentice a ruined new york city a
dead wong dormammu's sister umar and a
glimpse of kang the conqueror he then
wakes up with a third eye and hears the
voice of clia saying help me now again
because it's kind of coming out that
these leaks are seemingly accurate
this is really really cool clea and umar
are probably the coolest part of this
okay so let's talk about umar for a
second because a lot of you guys know
what's going on with the idea of like
dormammu right this guy who rules the
dark dimension all that kind of stuff in
the comic store mama has a sister and
his sister's name is umar and depending
on who's writing the story sometimes
she's more powerful than dormammu
usually she's not marvel comics is very
inconsistent with power levels and who's
more powerful than who and really
depends on when and all that kind of
stuff a really good example of this is
back in the 60s when doctor strange was
introduced he could basically do
anything he wanted to he could stop time
he could time travel he could alter
reality on a universal scale there was
no limit to what he could do but it was
almost impossible to tell stories about
him so they wrote this story where
basically he was brought in by the
vashanti who gave him like a book of his
power he was supposed to fight a war in
their name he refused to so they
stripped him of the mantle of sorcerer
supreme and then eventually gave it back
to him but he was like 50 less powerful
than he was before something along those
lines so again you know that kind of
stuff shifts all the time in marvel
comics now here's the deal with dormammu
and umar so in marvel comics the fall
team hail from a dimension which is
literally just pure magical energy right
they are beings made of magic so if
magic could get up and walk around it
would be the fall team they could do all
kinds of crazy stuff now they're not all
powerful and that is something that i
want to specify here but they are
incredibly powerful the way it
originally played out is that the fall
teams themselves basically just kind of
exists in their realm that umar and or
mamu had actually become interested in
like emotions and effectively what you
would call the elements of being a
sentient being right of being human
essentially and because that was
basically an outcast they ultimately
ended up getting engaged in some action
they ended up killing their mentor they
were ultimately exiled from the foul
teen dimension they took up residence in
the dark dimension conquered it and had
been ruling it ever since but the thing
about umar is that she offers another
part to this equation now if this is
true with it being umar this is really
really intriguing here the reason being
because we don't really know much about
dormammu himself let alone the potential
of introducing umar right so basically
we're taking a person that we know
almost nothing about and we're
introducing his sister and so it's kind
of like okay i mean we don't really even
know anything about that guy like how
are we supposed to go in terms of
knowing anything about his sister but
the important thing here is that with
these two people being in the mcu the
potential of them expanding the dark
dimension and giving us more information
showing us more things this is a cool
concept i still believe that dormammu is
in some form or fashion going to have a
hand in doctor strange too again i'm not
swearing by that but that's my theory
that he's going to be involved in some
way he's really more of a coming
together of just the kind of beings like
mephisto and nightmare and so on that we
would expect again it's kind of a theory
that i have but the other part of this
is clea now clea is really really cool
in the doctor strange mythos initially
she was a protege then she became his
girlfriend then she became his wife then
she divorced him and took half his stuff
that's not true she actually ended up
becoming a ruler of the dark dimension
for a time
but clea is one of these characters
where she is potentially exceedingly
powerful what it's also doing is
expanding on the doctor strange mythos
now having clea there in the picture as
you guys know when it comes to the mcu
usually when they introduce a new
character is kind of in with the new out
with the old that's kind of what seems
to happen so while i wouldn't say that
they were going to get rid of wong i
wouldn't be surprised if wang falls to
more of a background role if clio really
is going to become like the new protege
of doctor strange but going into the
kind of post credit scene because with
that mid credit scene itself it is
really cool the post-credits scene is a
lot more interesting and actually gives
us a lot of insight in terms of what's
going on with doctor strange too
particularly the role the illuminati
play the end credits scene is deadpool
along with cable domino and vanessa
exploring the illuminati facility due to
the illuminati's multiversal gates being
left open after the fight with wanda
deadpool is joking with the bodies of
some members including making a
reference to the office deadpool then
makes a joke while breaking the fourth
wall about patrick stewart's professor x
being dead again for the third time so
again with people kind of coming out and
being like yeah man these are pretty
accurate that looks like that's what's
gonna happen in the movie one of the
cool things about this right what's
really really cool about this is one it
brings deadpool into the mcu right i
mean we knew it was coming we knew that
was going to happen uh i imagine that if
this really is the case the top's gonna
come off that place right like i imagine
what'll happen is it'll basically be
like like it'll just be like the empty
facility and then like deadpool will
just peek his head around the corner be
like hello
anybody here like you guys know what i
mean like in true deadpool fashion it'll
be like cable and vanessa and domino and
them walking in there and just be like
come on wayne you know but like it's
cool now there are a couple things here
right the idea of him making a reference
to the office is obviously the you know
based on the idea that john krasinski is
playing reed richards the other part of
this is that with him making a joke of
course that patrick stewart's dead for
the third time that patrick stewart dies
in the movie now to me this is pretty
cool because if this is true it also
gives us massive insight into what's
going to happen in the future of the
marvel cinematic universe in doctor
strange 2 and even beyond the first
thing is that with patrick stewart quote
unquote dying for a third time uh i
imagine they probably won't bring him
back that the professor x that we get in
the x-men movies in the mcu will be a
wholly different person completely
different right it won't be patrick
stewart maybe it's james mcavoy i doubt
it would be him it would just be a
wholly different person that we've never
seen play the role before now the other
thing about this and if it's true it's
actually kind of disappointing that john
krasinski would play reed richards the
reason why is because unless reed
survives the events of doctor strange
too escapes whatever the destruction of
the illuminati facility happens to be or
whatever however things unfold and
essentially takes off and lands in the
marvel cinematic universe then what that
means is essentially seeing john
krasinski play reed richards is a
one-off that it's just one of those
things where potentially they're doing
it because fans have just been asking
for it for so long but once we actually
get the fantastic four as a team
properly introduced into the marvel
cinematic universe it'll be somebody
completely different which really begs
the question if you could pick one
person to play reed richards of the
fantastic four in the mcu who is not
john krasinski who would you pick and
you can't pick the guy from the original
fantastic four movies either you can't
pick him we're not gonna bring him back
somebody totally different someone who's
never played the role before who would
you pick to play that role but again
this is kind of a cool thing now in
terms of like kurzynski potentially
jumping ship and landing in the mcu
that's happened before and we've talked
about that right i mean that's one of
the big things that happens with the
marvel cinematic universe now and we can
leave comics out of it i mean there's
ample stories in marvel comics where
like a universe is being destroyed or
dying some of the denizens basically
jump ship and they land in a new
universe that's how you got the original
x-man nate gray just this stupidly
overpowered mutant in the main marvel
universe we saw it with days of future
past and days of future present with
rachel summers we've seen it with like
the mad jim jasper storyline we saw it
with hyperion from earth 13034 during
secret wars in 2015 by jonathan hickman
when he literally held two universes
apart for the span of like five or six
minutes he ultimately couldn't hold it
and even when the universes crashed into
each other and they were destroyed he
still lived ultimately he was grabbed by
advanced idea mechanics he was brought
into the to the main marvel universe and
was basically the main marvel universe's
most recent iteration of superman i'm
sorry i love jonathan hickman's avengers
new avengers single greatest comic book
story ever told i don't care what anyone
says it's phenomenal just
man so that's fun i swear to god i feel
like i can never make one of these
videos without talking about how amazing
jonathan hickman is fantastic for or
avengers and new avengers run is it's
just that's just the way that it is but
the thing about this is that the mcu
itself loki gave us that right loki
showed us that like one it's possible to
travel between universes across the
multiverse and that two a person can
jump ship from what's basically a dead
universe into another universe or jump
from a live universe into a dead
universe loki and sylvie did it
constantly right they were jumping from
universe to universe right reality to
reality sylvie had been doing it her
whole life loki was only more recently
introduced to it now seemingly if we
borrow from loki the idea or the ability
to jump from one universe to the next
using technological means so leaving out
somebody like america chavez that it is
potentially tied to operating outside of
space and time it makes it easier to do
right the tva existed outside of the
multiverse well technically at the very
end of the multiverse but still right at
that point all timelines converge into
the end of all things so basically
outside of the multiverse the thing
about this though is that if this is
really reed richards as we know him like
the marvel cinematic universe version of
reed richards which would be more
heavily based on the intelligence of
reed in the comics as opposed to the old
school fantastic four films this guy
figured out how to access the multiverse
years ago and i wouldn't even be
slightly surprised if reed richards in
the entire illuminati facility the
multiversal gates so the ability to
access the multiverse if that was all
read if reed was the one who figured out
how to do that he had the technology and
the means to achieve it and in essence
along with whatever the variant of iron
man happens to be in the illuminati it
basically built up their entire fortress
and then gave them the ability to access
the multiversal gates i wouldn't be
surprised if that was the case right
being able to access the multiverse in
marvel comics can be done in a just a
thousand different ways right there's
just so many different ways to do it but
regardless i think this is really cool
right so so i would say that while it is
slightly disappointing that we would see
john krasinski played reed richards in
doctor strange too with the potential
being that they would kill him off it
would be awesome if he actually survives
he basically escapes that and then ends
up taking off to the main marvel
universe the biggest question you have
to ask here and the biggest issue with
that is how do you get the rest of the
fantastic four because i have a hard
time believing that that john
krasinski's reed richards and doctor
strange too right like everything's
popping off and he's like okay we gotta
get out of here like everything's
collapsing you know he's like okay well
i'll just leave my wife and family i'll
just go here and start a new one right i
don't know if that would be the case now
it is possible and this is a really
really cool thing that i just kind of
happened to think of a second ago it is
possible that version of reed and the
fantastic four hail from a reality that
was destroyed whether it was done by
like wanda or whether it was done by
like duamamu or whatever this kind of
background menacing larger threat on a
multiversal scale happens to be right
whatever that case is it could be they
were like some of the last survivors so
the fantastic four as we know them right
reed bin johnny sue they exist in the
illuminati facility right reid's
family's just you know chilling relaxing
maxing out cool and shooting some b-ball
outside of the school when a couple of
guys who were up to no good started
making trouble in the neighborhood but
nonetheless you know it's entirely
possible they're just there and chilling
and we only really see reid or maybe we
see him meet with like the rest of his
family so we know the whole fantastic
four is there that gives them the
ability to leave and then show up in the
main marvel universe i don't know at
this point i'm kind of rambling and just
theorizing let me know what you guys
think down in the comment section
but let me know who you guys want to
play read that i am serious about if you
could pick one person to play reed
richard to the marvel cinematic universe
who has not played him yet let me know
who you think that person should be but
with that being said guys we're going to
bring this video to an end thank you all
for watching and i'll catch you all
later
peace